[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren so felderer 85 köpfe fünf
meinungen ein bewegter nachrichten tag
liegt hinter uns mit der meldung dass
deutschland eine neue familienministerin
hat grün politikerin lisa paus über die
neue personalie und andere emotionale
themen spreche jetzt um einen
großartigen gästen zum einen was wäre
für die nacht ohne ihn star kolumnist
auto und stammgast hans ulrich jörges
welt autorin susanne gaschke bestseller
autor und historiker dr dr reiner zitta
das wird dann liest bild politik
redakteur sebastian geisler uns alle
eint wie wahrscheinlich auch sie zu
hause - am leidenschaftlichen
debattieren über politik und
gesellschaftliche debatte sonst hätten
sie auch gar nicht eingeschaltet wenn
sie nicht genau sagen lassen würden
falls sie aber heute zum ersten mal film
nachschauen jeder von uns hat eine these
im gepäck über dir sprechen möchte
debattieren möchte und meine these heute
abend ist eine forderung die lautet ich
fordere die politik auf mich endlich ein
für alle mal in ruhe zu lassen was
corona betrifft nach zwei jahren
pandemie bin ich es leid dass politiker
und ernste meinen sie könnten sich
besser um meine gesundheit tun als ich
selbst er ist heute der vorsitzendes
welt ärzteverbandes frank ulrich
montgomery
so freuen sich denn ostern gemahnt maske
tragen abstand halten genauso wie die
letzten zwei jahre als hätten wir es
nicht schon tausendmal gehört auch
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
jetzt zur maske test abstand und das
obwohl deutschland in statistik nicht
sonderlich gut abschneidet in schweden
ist die lebenserwartung gegenüber
2009/10 jahr gestiegen während
deutschland mehr als vier monate
verloren hat auf welcher grundlage also
meint die politik und bürgern weiterhin
krone ratschläge zu erteilen
ich möchte es einmal ganz hat ausdrücke
mir reicht ist und ich bin ab jetzt auch
raus ich habe keine lust mehr von der
politik etwas vorschreiben zu lassen
wie geht das ganz ähnlich also große
sympathie es war aber von vornherein
klar dass die politik also von diesen
neuen spielsachen die sie dabei kommen
hat nicht so gerne so schnell wieder
würde lassen wollen wenn ich also dass
das länger hin dass vorschriften machen
dass da hat man sich in zwei jahren
unheimlich schnell daran gewöhnt ich
will jetzt bei hand man kann sagen es
ist vielleicht nicht die avantgarde der
ärzteschaft die sich geäußert und es hat
ja durchaus auch ärzte und
verbandsvertreter aus dem bereich
gegeben die ihn auch während der ganzen
phase öfter machen aufgerufen haben
insofern bin ich so ein bisschen
hoffnungsvoll wenn man durch die stadt
geht da hilft sicher jetzt auch das
schöne frühlingswetter dann sieht man
doch dass an stellen wo es nicht so
dramatisch lebensgefährlich ist zb auf
einem wenig besuchten wochenmarkt die
leute jetzt doch wieder mit mehr mit
offenem besicherung laufe auf dem
wochenmarkt haben sie völlig recht habe
ich das schon vor wochen beobachtet kann
es gar nicht fassen das sind fast fast
alle leute ohne maske rumgelaufen ich
hab mich wahnsinnig frei gefühlt es ist
ja in einigen gegenden von deutschland
noch finster also erstaunlicherweise im
liberalen hamburg das gilt ja noch als
hotspot da ist ja sehr viel verboten das
sind auch die ganz alten zuständig kann
es gar nicht glauben liberale hamburg
und in mecklenburg vorpommern fangen die
jetzt langsam an zu lockern weil die
ministerpräsidentin so als handlangerin
putins in verschiss geraten ist wird sie
irgendetwas in politisches machen muss
die fangen langsam an zu lockern
ansonsten liebe nena gebe ich dir
vollkommen recht man muss sich einfach
selbst befreien das ist übrigens immer
richtig selbstbefreiung also ich weiß
nicht ob sie den schönen satz kennen von
ronald reagan der hat mal gesagt die
zwölf furchterregendsten worte in der
englischen sprache sind ich komme hier
von der regierung dir zu helfen
da hat er schon recht damit und ich sag
mal so die these es gibt auch ein
menschenrecht eigentlich in ruhe
gelassen zu werden der bund jetzt gar
nicht nur auf caron also haben wir ganz
prinzipiell als ich sagt menschenrechte
in ruhe gelassen zu werden ganz
allgemein
ja ich finde ja eine erinnerung daran
wenn man jetzt zu ostern mit seiner
familie zusammenkommt da sind vielleicht
oma und opa dabei dann nochmal zu
erinnern ja wohl vielleicht vorher mal
testen das kann man ja machen aber es
sind doch keine unmündigen kinder wir
haben doch auch die nachrichten verfolgt
ja wir machen sie da wurde ja sogar als
journalisten sind ja eng kann das wissen
doch die menschen mittlerweile es
braucht doch nicht immer ja lass dich
testen maske auf diese ermahnungen man
kann doch selbst entscheiden wie man
sich verhält die leute sind nicht ruf
und ich möchte auch von da stimme ich
befürchte politikern nicht so als
unmündig war aber es gab ja von anfang
an ein unglaublich bevormundenden ton
absolute in der in der ganzen kampagne
auch fürs handy was ich hatte auch nie
lust mehr von den sparren erklären zu
lassen wie man sich die hände da wurde
schon beim händewaschen happy birthday
singen damit wir wissen
aber nicht so absurd sagt laurenz und
meine disziplin ist unsere beste medizin
also da hatte man ja das gefährt wenn
ihr gleich in zehn gebote auf gesagt
also es hat schon was erfolgs
erzieherische war die ursula von der
leyen können sich noch daran erinnern
wie hat sich die hände gewaschen und
dazu die europahymne gesummt und besser
als video gepostet hat das jemand
gesehen und am anfang ja also das war
wirklich so geraten
das war ihr bester beitrag
wahrscheinlich
in einer erstaunlichen satz von karl
lauterbach also heute ist ja diskutiert
worden über den dass eine geplante
entführung durch eine rechtsradikale
internetgruppe eine jet gruppe und
übrigen der sache die man ernst nehmen
sollte man soll sich da nicht drüber
erheben denn
auch wenn man die leute für spinner hält
ein einzeltäter der zur waffe greift
findet sich schnell also wir können uns
ja auch an händler erinnern deren hessen
von einem einzeltäter erschossen worden
es geht ganz schnell da muss man sehr
ernst nehmen auch wenn die als komplette
spieler auftreten er sagte jedenfalls in
seiner stellungnahme dazu er sehe jetzt
auch wie tief gespalten die gesellschaft
sei und er wolle etwas dazu tun die
wieder zusammenzubringen dann so was hat
er glaube ich überhaupt noch nie gesagt
sondern hat immer weiter zugespitzt und
holz gehackt und jetzt legt da
vielleicht mal die angst weg und wird
ein bisschen wie soll ich sagen
versöhnlicher also je war hoffe ich
jedenfalls aber dann hat er wieder
seinen ganzen wert eigentlich verloren
ich meine color hat aber braucht corona
ganz schlimm dass man ihren führen
wollten ein ich habe ja auch hier keine
hatte man oft geredet habe das ist
natürlich vor 25 jahren jemand an also
ich glaube dass der mann
als die politische wirkung angeht jetzt
vom fast rücktritt der mauer erledigt
kann im jahr einer der hat ja die die
impfpflicht nicht durchgesetzt hat er
nichts erreicht und es eigentlich schon
nach wenigen monaten gescheitert im amt
und eigentlich wäre reif für eine
auswechslung aber jetzt ist er natürlich
durch diese geplante entführung ist ja
irgendwie zur irgendwie wieder zu einer
kultfigur geworden und nicht anfassbar
also falls scholz mal darüber
nachgedacht hat ihn auszuwechseln das
tut er jetzt bestimmt nicht mehr hallo
herr lauterbach ist sicher wir werden im
herbst noch leben wenn was immer dann da
los ist kommt er wieder aus der kiste
aber herr joop als analytisch machte er
die legislaturperiode voll also wird er
in vier jahren noch im amt sein der man
n oder was weiß ich nicht danke gebe ich
auch keiner prognose habe ich wünsche es
mir nicht ich wünsche mir eine exakte es
ist der posten wo ich eine frau wünsche
die was vom fach versteht und nicht
einen so offensichtlich durch die
eigenen furien der eigenen seele
gehetzten man es ist ja auch so dass in
der spd fraktion sich glaube ich also
niemand vorher so richtig vorstellen
konnte dass also ein lauterbacher amt
bekleide da war man auch erstaunt und
scholz wollte ihn ja offensichtlich auch
nicht im kabinett haben also das ist ja
der eine kandidat der ihm wirklich rein
gedrückt worden ist und jetzt muss er
damit leben also ich habe jetzt nicht so
starke emotionen und gegen lauterbach
gehabt wie viele andere aber was ist
nicht verstehe jetzt vertritt der
politik teilweise gegen seine eigenen
überzeugungen ja und das finde ich das
passt im grunde genommen nicht so ganz
zu ja dass er zeigte aber eigentlich
hätte zurücktreten müssen er zeigt ja er
war gegen die lockerung der der das
immer so des gesundheitsschutzgesetzes
wer weiter gegen was die fdp
durchgesetzt hat aber hat es trotzdem
vertreten das hat er in einem atemzug
immer wieder vorgetragen da waren
natürlich wirklich ruiniert dadurch das
kann man nicht machen und er hat sich
als selbst korrigiert also ergibt eine
entscheidung an einem tag bekannte abend
eine talkshow bei lanz und nimmt die
entscheidung zurück solche sachen das
ist halt nicht machbar aber nun ist
erstmal fest im sattel wie man ihn noch
eine zeit lang ertragen müssen lena wird
ja immer noch ratschläge erhalten
bleiben da ich glaube ja schon dass man
darüber reden muss auch ich habe auch
eben diese statistik angesprochen was
mir ganz große angst es geht ja gerade
auf twitter zum beispiel dieser aktion
ich habe mitgemacht man dem hashtag das
ist eine initiative die aufgeschrieben
hat wer was gesagt hat ob du alles top
politiker ich muss sagen mit der seite
wie sie aufgemacht ist sind wir die sehe
ich nicht aber mit der aktion an sich
mal zusammen die ungeimpfte behandelt
wurde neunter das halte ich für sehr
sehr sinnvoll und da ist auch noch mal
meine frage an sie frau das gebiet sich
das denn entwickeln also müssen wir
nicht dass auch aufarbeiten was passiert
ist vor allem wenn jetzt statistiken
zeigen also so doll weil der deutsche
weg doch nicht ja also ich halte das für
dringend notwendig und es ist natürlich
jetzt eine schwierige politische
situation da wir ja nun sehr sehr
beschäftigt sind sehr zu recht mit dem
sehr viel größeren schreck kein problem
eine krise gerät das so ein bisschen ins
hintertreffen ich glaube wir brauchen
dringend eine aufarbeitung ich bin sehr
für eine enquete kommission die sich
nochmal ganz systematisch damit befasst
es auch vor dem hintergrund der
entsetzlichen bilder die wir aus
shanghai sehen ja doch noch einmal sehr
deutlich vor augen geführt wird dass
eine demokratische lösung einer in der
weise abgeschlossene gesellschaft nicht
sein kann natürlich war es hier nie so
schlimm aber die tendenzen waren doch
schon sehr übergriff ich gehe sehr
großzügig mit den grundrechten um und
man ist jetzt bereit das so ein bisschen
mit erleichterung unter den teppich zu
kehren das darf meiner meinung nach
nicht geschehen das ist auch wichtig zu
dokumentieren wer hat wer hat was gesagt
wo stehen wir denn tatsächlich bei den
sterberaten anja im vergleich zu anderen
ländern also und welche maßnahmen haben
denn überhaupt was gebracht die haben
sich ja hartnäckig geweigert also
sozusagen irgendwie zu evaluieren welche
maßnahme eigentlich was genau bewirkt wo
sich leute anstecken wer sich genau an
steckt ich habe neulich jetzt von einem
statistischen institut die zahl gelesen
dass also sagen die die wenigen toten
dass die 200 menschen tatsächlich noch
täglich gezählt werden die angucken
sterne sind nicht das sind natürlich
sterben ja nicht alkohol und hat mit
corona sterben die sind aber im schnitt
jetzt älter als das durchschnittsalter
vor der pandemie insgesamt war wie muss
man so muss man sich irgendwie verhalten
zur zur ehre dieser redaktion sagen es
kann eine junge frau aus dieser
redaktion die über dieses neue diese
neue plattform geschrieben hat und die
für mich erst bekannt gemacht hat und
das ist eine großartige journalistische
leistung fällt es einem nicht so einfach
sich damit durchzusetzen mit seiner
geschichte aber das hat sie getan und
das muss ich einfach mal sagen gute
redaktion ja wir haben bei schönach ganz
tolle redakteurinnen die sich immer
dafür 1 ist in dem fall war sehr
beatrice achterberg ist wirklich
großartig aber wie würden sie das denn
sagen herr doktor doktor zillmann wie
kann man verhindern dass in der zukunft
so etwas noch mal passiert oder wie kann
man es jetzt auch dokumentiert ich meine
essen ganze familien daran zerbrochen
dass die menschen in ungeimpft und geben
unterschieden haben da gab es zehn ivan
ja furchtbar
also für mich ist das eigentlich
interessante an der ganzen geschichte
dass wir hier ein gigantisches staats
und politik versagen gehabt haben und
zwar leider halt nicht nur diesem
bereich am anfang das ende sie haben
völlig von den anfangs seien also hat
man nichts funktioniert man spricht
immer vom vom markt versagt aber hier
ist das politikversagen als das
absurdeste war ja da macht man so
fälschungssichere
gutscheine die man der apotheke dann
einlösen kann gegen die maske ist mir
bis heute nicht der lage eine
fälschungssichere impfausweis zu machen
ja und ich meine wir könnten alle endlos
sachen aufzählen und man sieht sie aber
überall ja wenn man sieht die bundeswehr
ist mehr oder minder schrotthaufen heute
digitalisierung fehlanzeige ja und wo
man hinguckt sehe ich eigentlich überall
staatsversagen das genau das also
anhänger immer so auf dass die leute
ständig von marktversagen reden ich sagt
reden wir mal vom staatsversagen das ist
noch größer als marktfrau sagen da habe
ich auf ihrer seite das fing ja damit an
dass herr wiler der chef des ake ganz
zum anfang gesagt hat die maske taugt
nix sie brauchen wir eigentlich genauso
wie hat das los ja jetzt ist einer der
großmufti ist des masten der der des
maskenballs soll dann durfte mein tücher
benutzen ja auch eine zeit lang und
natürlich auch sagen sagen ich will die
politik nicht in schutz nehmen aber
viele menschen sind auch begeistert mit
gelaufen also werden zustimmungs zahlen
zu der energiepolitik regierung am
anfang waren bei 80 prozent das muss man
sich mal vorstellen und wir waren immer
ein kleiner relativ versprengter haufen
der gesagt hat halo aber das grundrecht
aus und das bild erscheint
auch eine freiheitlich orientierte frau
das hat mich an diesem volk negativ
überrascht das hätte ich nicht für
möglich gehalten wie staatsgläubig die
mehrheit der neuen und welche
einschränkungen ihrer freiheit sie
klaglos hinnehmen über lange zeit dass
es ist vieles wieder denkbar für mich
geworden und daran sehen wir auch dass
man ja auch immer direkt aufpassen muss
wenn vielleicht wieder jemand neues auf
die bilden fläche trend ja auch die
menschen einschränken will und du hast
uns heute sebastian den neuen kalender
machen mitbringen mitgebracht kaufen
kann man so sagen tatsächlich gerne auch
mir geht es nämlich um klaus müller das
ist der neue chef der bundesnetzagentur
ein bemerkenswerter mann der tritt
tatsächlich so auf als wurde karl
lauterbach einen coach mit seinen
ideen wie wir jetzt alle energie
einsparen können nun sollte man
sicherlich natürlich energie einsparen
wenn das gas möglicherweise aus russland
am ende abgeschaltet wird oder wie auch
immer das ist sicherlich hat seine
durchaus seine berechtigung aber dieser
mann der kommt hier mit vorschlägen der
ist nervensäge mittlerweile der sagt zum
beispiel so was wie singles in großen
wohnungen sollten diese großen wohnungen
nicht mehr so sehr heizen wie bisher der
sagt es reicht doch auch mal 17 grad in
der wohnung zum beispiel da sage ich mir
17 grad warm ich es haben will oder
nicht das entscheide ich vielleicht als
bürger doch selbst und sein neuester
knaller ist er sagt wir müssen jetzt mal
überlegen ob es überhaupt noch
angemessen ist sie mal die woche zu
duschen da sag ich mal dieser mann
überschreite seine kompetenzen hat das
bei carlotta macht auch angefangen ich
glaube wir werden von 1000 wunder noch
einiges verloren aber eindeutig lieber
herr müller so oft es nicht ich dusche
so lange und wann ich will wenn ich zum
frühdienst fahre da bin ich ja geduscht
hingehen und nicht ich weiß nicht wie
oft er duscht aber hat mal jemand neben
ihm gestanden
wir haben angefragt würden gerne mit ihm
sprechen immer sondershausen ideen und
er verweigert sich dem arbeit ist
während genau meine frage wie oft müssen
sie denn also ich kenne
schleswig-holstein dieser faktor ist
ja man muss sagen er war umweltminister
in schleswig holstein von den grünen und
das ist ebenso dieses hinein wirken in
private lebensbereiche was ich nicht in
ordnung finde es gibt eine eine sehr
ernstzunehmende brücke zwischen corona
politik und der politik die sie
schildern die beginnt jetzt der karl
lauterbach hat von geschätzten jahr oder
anderthalb jahren mal gesagt dass man
die einschränkung der freiheit die da
eingeführt wurden auch später noch
brauchen werde zur durchsetzung der
klimapolitik seine finanzen der
schlimmste satz den lauterbach überhaupt
gesagt wo ist das schlimmste
das war es eine mahnung an uns wir
müssen uns daran gewöhnen dass das
dauerhaft der fall ist erst acht ja auch
diese dieser diese corona pandemie
werden wir noch 20 30 jahre haben davor
bewahren muss der himmel das glauben wir
nicht mehr da brauchen gar nicht mehr
mitzukommen aber wenn es andere gibt die
das aufnehmen in der klimapolitik und
die sagen jetzt müssen wir auch
freiheitsbeschränkungen bewegt
beschränkungen unserer beweglichkeit und
so weiter dort einführen dann haben wir
ein echtes problem
und es sind viele die das aufnehmen in
gewerkschaften in den kirchen wann beim
weltwirtschaftsforum in davos
erstaunlicherweise zum teil auch in den
unternehmen und da gruselt es mir dann
also wirklich auch sehr und ich finde es
genial waren sind wir ausgebildet immer
wieder nennen ja und es gibt ja eine
interessante parallele die ich noch sehr
pikant findet sozusagen es hat ja vor
einigen jahren mal theo sarrazin gesagt
man müsste ja vielleicht immer die
wohnung ganz so hoch heizen und können
ja vielleicht auch mal ein wollpullover
überziehen das ging dann in richtung hat
hier empfänger es wurde sehr negativ
aufgenommen also im grunde seine ächtung
begann auch also unter anderem mit der
kritik an hilfe man an diesen an diesem
satz wenn ein grüner das sagt ist es
offensichtlich in ordnung war mit 17
gerade in der wohnung bin ich
einverstanden wenn es draußen 35h
hdr ein mann wie sehen sie das denn sind
wir deutschen vielleicht auch einfach
freiheits fall dass wir überhaupt so
etwas akzeptieren
ja also freiheit hat nicht so eine
richtig große tradition ja dann muss man
sagen im verhältnis zu anderen ländern
und was ich im grunde schlimm finde auch
an dem beispiel ist wie jetzt gerade die
der schlimme krieg in der ukraine
instrumentalisiert wird um jetzt alle
diese möglichen einschränkungen zu
begründen also jetzt kommen die uns
sagen
tempobeschränkung auf der autobahn und
so weiter also ganz alte forderungen die
jetzt aber alle recycelt werden aber
alle mit der neuen begründung also wir
müssen jetzt der ukraine helfen und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt weniger
duschen ja deswegen müssen das ist im
grunde genommen also schäbig sondern
ganz schlimmes ein ernstes thema so zu
instrumente ja es gibt ja eine breite
bewegung den freiheitsbegriff überhaupt
zu zerlegen denn beobachte schon eine
ganze zeit und zwar gedruckten in
artikeln von von politikwissenschaftlern
von philosophen von kulturschaffenden
ich hab da neulich im deutschlandfunk an
einem samstagvormittag samstag war das
glaube ich oder sonntag bin ich mir ganz
sicher einen langen vortrag eines
wissenschaftlers gehört der sich darauf
spezialisiert hat in dieser sendung
deutschlandfunk den freiheitsbegriff zu
zerlegen dass der
inflationär gebraucht werde dass man
ihnen gar nicht mehr so brauche das er
überholt sein dass es um verantwortung
gehe nicht mehr an freiheit und
ähnliches und diesen tenor ich habe das
auch gedruckt gesehen hat da muss man
sehr darauf achten und man muss dann
finde ich wenn anders begegnet sofort
dagegen auf aber das wird von vielen
kollegen durchaus vertreten ja und also
meine philosophie sozusagen eine
beschäftigung mit philosophie ist so
lange her ich konnte nicht sagen ob das
eigentlich hegel oder marxist aber es
wird jetzt immer definiert also freiheit
als einsicht in die notwendigkeit oder
auslassungen des umstandes dass
irgendjemand bestimmen muss raster in
die notwendigkeit ist woher muss man
erst mal frei gewesen sein denn auch man
beschränkt ja und wer definiert ihn und
wenn ich absolut also kann ich ihnen
zustimmen ich habe da selbst ein ganz
eigenartiges erlebnis gehabt ich
schreibe ja öfters für die neue zürcher
zeitung und da habe ich einen
antikapitalistischen philosophen
kritisiert und er hat also einen blick
gegen mich geschrieben und dann schreibt
der mittelmann ist ein prediger der
freiheit das war welches nicht als
kompliment gemeint vergiftet das war
praktisch das war die höchste form der
geringschätzung und da hab ich gesagt
also dass ich mir gerne an also prediger
der freiheit finde ich gar nicht
verkehrt ein einstieg sein letztes als
freiheits nazi bezeichnet
dementsprechend die freiheit hat zu
wenig lobby nimmst du das auch im moment
ja das nehme ich tatsächlich so warm wie
gesagt dass hineinwirken in private
lebensbereich der politik und das auch
das moralische aufladen wie sich eben
auch schon sagten dass man sagt also
tempolimit wer schneller fährt als 130
oder wir gegen die wir gegen ein
tempolimit ist der riskiert er führt
quasi den krieg in der ukraine mit oder
so so das ist einfach nicht in ordnung
genauso bei der korona politik weil dazu
kritische anmerkungen hat der will dass
menschen sterben das ist natürlich
völliger unsinn oder bei der
flüchtlingspolitik da haben wir das
natürlich auch ganz massiv gesehen auch
der freundschaften zerbrochen haben wir
ja auch schon darüber gesprochen das ist
natürlich dramatisch ich finde es
schlimm wir sind offensichtlich als land
oder als gesellschaft in deutschland
nicht in der lage bestimmte themen in
einer gesellschaftlichen debatte zu
verhandeln ohne andere auszugrenzen und
zu schlecht menschen zu erklären dass
nämlich in großbritannien zum beispiel
anders waren gut die haben sich über den
black series oft sage ich auch dazu aber
wir haben offensichtlich nicht diese
kultur wie das in den angelsächsischen
ländern ist dass man in einer debatte
argumente austauschen ohne den anderen
abzuwerten und zum schlecht menschen zu
erklären ja also wir haben sehr
kritische stimmung hier immer jan ein
schwarzweiß freund feind leben oder tod
durch und so zwischentöne sind nicht so
unser also interesse gezeigt aber auch
mal
was ist jetzt an der korona debatte
trotzdem wissen schiefern also zum
beispiel regen sich sehr über die masken
wie man auf mich selbst ja aber erst mal
wenn sich die leute genau so aufregen
würden auch über andere
freiheitseinschränkung ja zum beispiel
einschränkung der wirtschaftlichen
freiheit es gibt in deutschland 25.000
bauvorschriften das ist auch für mich
und auch die ganze sagen wir
einschränkungen in der der geistige
freiheit das ist für mich so ein
hauptthema finde ich auch ein bisschen
schade bei meiner eigenen partei als ich
bin jetzt seit 26 jahren der fdp und ich
habe immer gesagt die beiden hauptthemen
müssten doch sein dass wir für die
wirtschaftliche freiheit eintreten aber
auch für die geistige freiheit einträten
also gegen diese einzelmarkt sonderthema
bauvorschriften nochmal wiederkommen
wird die spannende diskussion er ist
nämlich wert irrsinnig was sich da
abspielt aber das mit den
bauvorschriften spannendes thema haben
wir jetzt vielleicht einfach durch
corona erst mal bemerkt wie sehr unsere
freiheit beschnitten wird und reagieren
jetzt vielleicht auch das erste mal
drauf naja ich finde es ja gut fände es
auch auf andere bereiche übertragen wird
aber ich habe so das gefühl das ist
eigentlich nicht so geschieht also die
leute regen sich sehr über diese ganzen
chor ohne beschränkungen auf aber ich
habe jetzt nicht erfahren dass die
menschen sich im gleichen maße aufregen
über die ständige beschränkung von
wirtschaftlicher freiheit die ich viel
gefährlicher findet noch alles da
müssten wir mehr darüber sprechen naja
und auch ein diskurs klima eben dass das
also sehr unpersönlich ist und also die
andere meinung ist eben nicht anders
oder von mir aus schlecht argumentiert
und so sind sie es böse ist unmoralisch
und das ist ich habe aber auch kein
richtiges mittel wie man davon wieder
runterkommen ich habe den eindruck das
ist in den vergangenen jahren wirklich
noch mal dramatisch schlimmer geworden
in den letzten weiß ich nicht fünf sechs
jahren also es war als tendenz immer
schon vorhanden und es gab natürlich
seit 20 30 jahren debatten über
politische correctness die aus den
amerikanischen universitäten in
generation auch zusammen her schwappte
aber ich finde es hat nochmals schub der
unversöhnlich gerade es gibt auch mehr
widerspruch guck mal ich meine wie der
herr jörges zum beispiel ja so früher
war ich da auch manchmal andere meinung
als er heute auch noch manchmal aber
aber der natürlich schwierigkeiten
irgendjemandem es war ein exemplar das
ist doch nur natürlich ja aber wie
gesagt noch einmal das eben auch leute
die die wir heute brauchen und die die
auch laut ihre stimme erheben und von
denen gibt es eigentlich ich würde sagen
er mehr als vor 20 jahren also ist
erstmal ein gefühlt ja mein glück wird
es anders ich glaube dass die medien
sehr eintönig geworden sind und dass es
nur noch wenige leitartikler
beispielsweise in großen zeitungen gibt
die so schreiben dass man sie lesen will
mir geht es so wie es euch geht es ist
ein stromlinienförmigkeit eingerissen
dass man sehr schaut was machen die
anderen mit ihren die anderen passe ich
daran das spektrum und so dass das nehme
ich tatsächlich auf erhalte ich auch für
sehr problematisch ich finde man sollte
immer die die ergebnisse seiner eigenen
recherche und insofern auch eine
entsprechende kommentierung bringen und
nicht irgendwie sich auf ein meinungs-
korridor verengen lassen das ist
eigentlich der tod des journalismus wenn
man so agiert also ich finde es
eigentlich bei den printmedien gutmann
hat die welt man hat die neue züricher
zeitung als die bild zeitung da gibt es
noch eine gewisse ausgewogenheit ja aber
im fernsehen ja und ich rede nicht nur
von öffentlichen fernsehen schritt auch
vom privaten fernsehen das ist ja hier
mal eine ausnahme nennen sie mir noch
mal eine nicht linke talkshow in
deutschland eine dezidiert sagen wir mal
konservative oder von mir aus auch
libertäre oder was weiß ich was ich
würde sowas gerne moderieren das letzte
aber er war eigentlich ein sender sie
können es ja noch was der decke hat
löwenthal war doch eigentlich der letzte
konservative oder klose schon seit
neujahr aber hinterher und seitdem also
egal was man da sieht ob das die länder
oder meischberger sagte ich dass die
alle dezitiert links sind aber es gibt
auch keinen einzigen jetzt mal wo man
sagt das ist jetzt dass wir doch auch
dazu gehören zum pluralismus dass das so
dass jetzt eine war dabei wie der titel
man da machst du einen ganz anderen es
ist halt alles mainstreamig dass er dann
keine meinungen mehr feststellt oder
einlädt dorthin die irgendwie mal aus
dem rahmen fallen was die leitartikler
angeht ich kann mich noch ein robert
leicht bei der süddeutschen zeitung hin
ob da ist dann später zur zeit gegangen
bei der süddeutschen zeitung war ein
leitartikler der richtig
eigene eigen stellung hatte weil er
dinge so kommentiert hat wie sie andere
nicht kommentiert haben da hat man schon
alleine angefangen zu lesen weil sein
name drüber stand und das sehe ich heute
bei der süddeutschen zeitung nicht mehr
aber das gilt ja für die themen
insgesamt also früher wenn sie also als
volontärin kamen mit einem thema und
gesagt haben ein toller artikel in der
süddeutschen kann ich da auch darüber
schreiben hat der chef gesagt nee wieso
ist eine geschichte der süddeutschen
also wenn du nichts ganz neues hast
vergiss es heute fragt jeder chef warum
haben nicht auch also es ist eine selbst
gleichschaltung rumstehen entsprechenden
aufruf dass ich das verbessert und der
aufruf von der doctor doctor einer 10
mal dass er gerne in new york schon
öffentlich rechtlichen
wir haben hier einen bewerber und ich
verspreche ihnen bei uns darf man ja
alles sagen was man möchte müssen wir
das reich der freiheit und ich glaube
die these die jetzt service mit hat die
würden sie auch nicht im öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk hören will der hat
mir schon gesprochen also mail
widersprechen
ich beschäftige mich weil mich das nach
wie vor interessiert mit der geplatzten
reise unseres bundespräsidenten nach
kiew es sind jetzt die präsidenten
polens und der drei baltischen
republiken gemeinsam gefahren zu viert
sie haben
steinmeier zurück gelassen und haben
sich dort in kiew aufs herzlichste mit
dem ukrainischen präsidenten selensky
verstanden hier stellen sich dabei zwei
fragen steinmeier ist nicht eingeladen
worden weil er nicht opportun war in
kiew und eigentlich hätte ich erwartet
dass der polnische präsident der die
reise organisiert hat diese gruppenreise
in
kiew protestiert bzw insistiert darauf
dass alle fahren dürfen reisen dürfen
auch steinmeier entweder alle oder
keiner das halte ich für eine
selbstverständlichkeit eigentlich bei
sona geschichte aber so ist es nicht
gekommen sondern die sind alleine
gefahren und ich erwarte eigentlich dass
es nicht nur eine solidarität mit der
ukraine gibt sondern auch eine
solidarität innerhalb europas dazu zählt
das für mich auch dass man einen solchen
mann nicht hinten runterfallen lässt
sondern dass man ihn mitnimmt und auf
seiner rechte bad
zweite frage genauso dringend warum ist
eigentlich steinmeier überhaupt zu
dieser gruppenreise gekommen was treibt
ihn dazu ich meine erst der präsident
deutschlands das ist die große
zentralmacht europas eigentlich sollte
alleine fahren seine eigene reise
organisieren zumal ja es sehr viele
meinungsunterschiede zwischen der
ukraine und deutschland gibt über die
müsste dort gesprochen werden
den ski und zwar in ruhe ohne das andere
präsidenten auch noch dabei sitzen zu
fünft kann man davon gar nichts mehr
besprechen mein eindruck ist steinmeier
hat sich dem angeschlossen weil er unter
bedeckung von anderen sich nach kiew
schleichen wollte er hat ein schlechtes
gewissen weil er früher sehr nah bei
putin war er sollte aber den mut
aufbringen sich den fragen die an kiew
gestellt bekommt auch zu stellen das
sind natürlich fragen nach deutschen
waffenlieferungen überhaupt nach
unterstützung denen will er ausweichen
also für mich zeigt sich an dem ganzen
an der ganzen affäre
das veränderte die veränderte
wahrnehmung deutschlands auch die
veränderte geltung deutschlands in
europa wir sind ja schon seit einiger
zeit die feiglinge europas weil wir
nicht der lage waren harte sanktionen
gegen russland durchzusetzen
insbesondere ein energie boykott da war
ich sehr dafür kommt nicht die banken
sind zum teil verschont worden die
gazprombank kann weiter geschäfte machen
mit uns und zweitens weil wir erst sehr
spät und sehr
vorsichtig und dann auch noch
dilettantisch zu waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine übergegangen sind also wir
waren die ist lang
die die feiglinge europas und jetzt
werden wir auch noch zu den deppen
europas weil europa über uns lacht wir
haben einen kanzler der sich nicht
entscheiden kann in welche richtung
einschlägt und wir haben einen
präsidenten der sich nach kiew
schleichen möchte damit er nicht
unangenehmen fragen
gestellt wird und so geht es nicht ich
weiß nicht wie das mit dieser regierung
und mit diesem präsidenten weitergehen
soll eigentlich wäre geneigt zu sagen
steinmeier müsse abtreten aber dass er
gerade neu gewählt worden das wird nicht
passieren
also ich stimme ihnen bei einem zu der
zweck der reise aus sicht von steinmeier
wäre es gewesen sich reinzuwaschen ja
und genau deswegen
widersprechen aber bei der ersten these
die sie gesagt haben war da ist es
richtig dass die ukraine das nicht
mitgemacht hat haben sie das bild
gesehen im fernsehen wie sich die alles
so die die hände ja die haben sie als
herzliches jahre stand können sich
vorstellen da die hand vom steinmeier
dabei ja also das wird auch wirklich
vollkommen hat natürlich lange nicht
hätte nicht stattgefunden
wir haben völlig recht das war das war
eine glückseligkeit dieser vier
ostdeutschen präsidenten mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten und ich glaube
auch dass die gefahren sind ohne ihn ist
ein beleg dafür dass sie erstens kein
wert auf ihn gelegt haben er war ihnen
wurscht und zweitens wollten sie auch
zeigen dass sie mit steinmeiers
positionen nicht einig sind also
insofern sie manchmal die habe ich gerne
hinten runterfallen lassen sie haben
sagt solidarität europas aber die würde
doch gerade durch den steinmeier
zerstört weil ich mein radio die die
polen aber auch eigene steht die
mehrheit in der eu war doch ganz cap
tisch gegenüber dieser russlandpolitik
auch bei bayer aus dem 2 und wenn jemand
die solidarität gestört hat dann war es
doch gerade jemand wieder wie der
steinmeier der immer diesen pro reli
kurs vertreten hat denn den hat er jetzt
auch in q1 noch den hat er ja abgelegt
jedenfalls sagt er das sei und jetzt
dass er jetzt ist er nun mal der
repräsentant deutschlands und zwar der
staatschef und den staatschef auszuladen
eines landes das doch unterm strich vor
allem als wirtschaftshilfe angeht sehr
viel leistet für die ukraine ist
eigentlich unerträglich und das muss uns
auch unerträglich sein ja es ist vor
einigen und praktisch insofern war die
ukraine da wahrscheinlich gut beraten
weil es ja vom eigentlichen problem ab
layers aber ich kann den effekt also
erstmal erst einmal selber gibt sich
viel mühe jetzt nicht allzu beleidigt zu
erscheinen wissen dass er was auch
anders kann also insofern wenn er jetzt
keine ganz große sache draus machen
müssen jetzt auch nicht andere für ihn
mit beleidigt sein soll man kann das
einfach zu den akten legen als ja die
ausladung durch ein land das gerade
zerbombt wird wenn die menschen ermordet
vergewaltigt werden und personals
übrigens insofern ist man vielleicht
sozusagen dann auch etwas kritisch mit
einem mann der ja wie steinmeier sich
der halb gare entschuldigt hat für seine
position das muss man sagen also nicht
dieses ich habe mich in klar also komma
wie auch viele andere kommen geirrt und
da muss man sagen ja und viele andere
hatten sich aber auch nicht geirrt in
bezug auf das was russland haben mit der
ukraine vor hat und die amerikaner haben
uns gewarnt die polen haben uns gewarnt
die beiden haben uns gewarnt und
steinmeier chef des kanzleramtes und
außenminister es wird keinen besser
informierten man in deutschland gegeben
haben nein zu sagen ich hatte hier auch
leute in runden muss ich jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich sagen die sich auch hier haben
was putin betrifft die frau heute genau
gesprächen nur leute die sich gehört
haben so und man da hätte ich gedacht
dass er den krieg führt so unvorstellbar
und dementsprechend finde ich manchmal
ich finde wirklich dass wir im moment
auch steinmeier schon in einem ausmaß
rumhacken und diesen mann hinhängen wo
wir auch sagen was okay das ist unser
bundespräsident deren präsentiert uns
alle und wenn ich jetzt mal ganz ehrlich
sein darf am tisch die ukraine hätte ihn
empfangen müssen uns die lenski aber es
gibt viele deutsche die sich auf die
sich wirklich ja die im flüchtlingsheim
arbeiten die alles machen wir schicken
hilfen hin und dann zu sagen empfängt
unseren bundespräsidenten nicht kann ich
nicht nachvollziehen aber jetzt ist
inzwischen die note aufgetaucht über die
wird berichtet mit die als ausladung
steinmeiers interpretiert wurde die note
der der ukrainischen regierung an die
deutsche botschaft in kiew da heißt es
sinngemäß drin dass eine allein reise
von steinmeier sinnvoller und
fruchtbarer wäre und auch für die
ukraine akzeptabler als damit den
anderen vier und mitzuschwimmen diese
meinung teile ich total ja es hätte ja
von anfang an machen sollen sich den
schwierigkeiten stellen und sagen müssen
ich bin der bundespräsident ich kann
nicht über waffenlieferungen entscheiden
ich verstehe aber ihre anliegen gut und
er hätte vielleicht ein bisschen was
davon zurück an scholz spielen können
jedenfalls muss er den mumm aufbringen
alleine zu reißen zu fünft also in
dieser note hat sich die ukrainische
regierung noch darauf berufen dass
natürlich in dieser insel kriegslage
alleine schon der empfang von fünf
staatschefs aus dem ausland schon eine
logistische problematik hat und eine
sicherheits problematik natürlich auch
verrückte idee sagt die amerikaner die
beiden unsere verbündeten in der nato
und in der eu haben gewarnt also es gab
artikulierte klare positionen und als
chef der geheimdienste sozusagen also
kein mann in deutschland hatte besseren
zugang zu mehr informationen als frank
walter steinmeier insoweit ist es sagen
wir mal es ist schade dass er nicht
früher zu einem anderen urteil gekommen
also ich habe auch wirklich zweifel dass
es diese sogenannte zeitenwende gibt ja
ich meine das kennen wir doch aus dem
privatleben ja mensch der das von heute
auf morgen ändert das passiert doch gar
nicht wir alle haben das geänderte
gesetz geändert aber das ging bei jahre
jahrzehnte die auch ja wie ging es
manchmal plötzlich
wirkliche änderung sie haben die
brauchen auch nur bereit und wenn einer
so von heute auf morgen geändert also
ich war da gleich vollkommen skeptisch
das nehme ich auf dem steinmeier nicht
ab und ich habe heute also weiter über
medien gerettet haben ein toller artikel
kann ich jedem empfehlen faz getreide
ganze seite über steinmeier und wenn man
den artikel gelesen ja tolle artikel
also dann kann man eigentlich nicht mehr
sagen er hätte jetzt mitfahren sollen ja
immer frei er hat sich geändert also das
ist mir dann auch zu einfach zu sagen ja
im nachhinein und so weiter er ist einer
der vielleicht der zentrale architekt
dieser russland politik gewesen die
beigetragen hat so eine situation wie
wir sie jetzt in der ukraine haben also
wir hätten möglich was wäre gewesen wenn
und so aber wir haben es abhängig
gemacht von den russischen
gaslieferungen das war schon ein ganz
dramatisch schwerer fehler dafür steht
er mit in der verantwortung und dann
einfach jetzt im nachhinein zu sagen
sorry wir haben uns geirrt ich habe mich
geändert das reicht eben auch drei hat
sich auch nicht geändert ist man muss
doch eigentlich davon ausgehen dass in
so einer situation wenn sich die ganze
welt ändert das hat sie ja die welt hat
sich geändert jedenfalls für europäische
dass dann ein politiker sagt mit dem was
ich bisher getan habe bin ich nicht mehr
der richtige der in dieser veränderten
welt eine wichtige funktion einnehmen
darf weil ich da nicht mehr glaubwürdig
bin und ich gehe das macht natürlich
keiner das ist ja in deutschland auch
total unüblich geworden und herr titel
man ich gebe ihm komplett recht mit der
frage der der zeitenwende die haben die
doch alle nicht in den köpfen ein
solider rücktritt frank walter
steinmeier ja wer ich finde ja und zwar
völlig unabhängig von dieser reise nach
kiew die hat das sozusagen auf die
spitze getrieben da hat man das problem
erkannt er versucht dem zu entkommen er
versucht sich klein zu machen er wird
sich unter anderem staatschefs
verstecken aber er muss den mut
aufbringen wenn schon dann alleine zu
reisen und sich den fragen zu stellen
und den den ukrainern zu erklären warum
er früher eine andere position hat man
warum er erkannt hat dass sie heute
falsch ist aber in den köpfen in berlin
gibt es die zeitenwende nicht die gibt
es auch bei olaf scholz nicht denken
alle noch daran dass irgendwann putin
weiter regiert nach dem krieg und mit
dem wollen sie dann weiterhin reden
besuchen und geschäfte machen ist sind
alle er auf mützenich linie im prinzip
ja also wer die beginnt sich in der spd
jedenfalls massiv durch aufsetzen und da
hat der kanzler ein echtes problem und
ich meine andererseits wäre er in einer
starken situation er hat die zeitenwende
verkündet und wir haben diese
außenpolitische lage so wie sie ist also
sozusagen jetzt zu sagen da muss man
andere fraktionschefin wäre der stärkste
moment also genau jetzt könnte das tun
aber offensichtlich fehlt ihm die stärke
also schön dass herr roth hat eine tolle
rolle gespielt so ist also das hat der
herr sehr gefallen und ich ja ganz
überraschend der hofreiter also ich weiß
hat niemand auf ja dafür aber bei dem
habe ich so ein bisschen das gefühl denn
haben die nicht zum minister gemacht und
jetzt gibt das war richtig so zurück ja
er wäre jetzt eine reihe jetzt war der
richtige
das etwas halb scherzhaft aber nur zu
sagen der richtige verteidigungsminister
jeden fall bei lambrecht auf gar nichts
da muss jetzt einer hinterher was der
sie für die sache interessiert hat und
der hof weiter interessiert sich
plötzlich sehr irak für diese waffe
nicht
da ist so absonderlich wie die jetzige
lage ist kann gar nicht
habe ich wirklich das gefühl wir sind
die deppen europas so absolut
alles von abrecht ist ja nicht so dass
wir sagen ja oder selbst meine frisur -
aber ich unterstelle mal dass er wüsste
wie man ein gewehr hält also dass man
den hof nicht an die schuld an
wo ich da sagen muss ich hab da
sympathien für verbrechen also und jetzt
hat ernsthaftes wort zu dieser regierung
zusagen über über steinmeier haben auch
schon geredet die ist doch reif für eine
kabinettsumbildung nach ganz kurzer zeit
da muss frau lambrecht weg und da müsste
eigentlich wenn das jetzt nicht passiert
wäre mit der aufgeflogenen entführung
müsste eigentlich auch lauterbach
ausgewechselt werden der hat in der
politik der korona beckham vollkommen
versagt und da muss man müsste eine neue
figur an suns ins ministerium kommen
wenn die regierung sprechen wir nach
einer ganz kurzen unterbrechung und auch
darüber wer jetzt eigentlich die neue
familienministerin ist bis gleich
also da kann ich ein lauter brauchen und
nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
fazit meine damen und herren bei 14 85
köpfen sind meinungen vor jeder von uns
hat ein thema mitgebracht was ihn bewegt
ärgert freut oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht privatjet buschi jörges
limetten radler ist aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der damen führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russland
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur der afg zu überlassen lasst
den leuten noch mal den spaß wir sehen
da etwas was eigentlich fatale ist in
der politik bei den journalisten deren
job ist es doch gerade abweichende
meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig
vielleicht einmal kurz ein
doch das ist übliche andrack träger aus
dass britney und ich habe meinen
beifahrer eine sache immer bekommen er
kümmert sich darum niemand gibt es
bargeld in bisher ganz kleinen auch
darüber sprechen lassen sagt nicht
fertig richtig wohl ist die aufgabe von
journalismus einfach
die verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück liebe
zuschauer wir sind zurück und wir legen
jetzt direkt los mit welt autorin
susanne gaschke mit einem sehr
tagesaktuellen thema
ich beschäftige mich natürlich mit der
eigenen und der neuen familienministerin
und haben gerade schon über die qualität
der regierung geredet und ich hab in dem
zusammenhang kommt nicht ganz vorbei
auch mal über quoten und proporzwahl zu
reden und identitätspolitik im weitesten
sinne also war ja regierung heutzutage
offensichtlich fast systematisch daran
gehindert sind die positionen mit leuten
zu besetzen die das irgendwie gut können
oder davor erfahrung haben sondern es
wird also quotiert wie wild also mann
frau als jungen links rechts natürlich
immer regionalproporz nordrhein
westfalen mecklenburg vorpommern dann
gibt es vielleicht noch so
sonderkategorien frau feser sollte eine
schöne startposition haben für den
wahlkampf in hessen wo sie dann ja
spitzenkandidatin der spd werden will
wir haben mit frau lambrecht sicher
niemand der sozusagen mit der bundeswehr
im blut aufgewachsen ist also die
fremdelt ja doch sehr und hat große
schwierigkeiten
und ja wir haben jetzt die situation
frau spiegel musste gehen die neue
kandidatin konnte aber auf gar keinen
fall ein mann sein also die vorstellung
dass wir einfach mal einen
heterosexuellen mann als familien müssen
völlig undenkbar es musste wieder eine
linke grüne frau sein das heißt wir
mauern uns oder die regierung hat sich
somit ihren kriterien allen dass sie
sozusagen für den qualitäts blick gar
keinen platz mehr hat ich weiß jetzt
nicht so zu sagen was die neue
ministerin sie hat sich immerhin meine
zwei themen befasst aus dem bereich
familienpolitik nicht mit der
kindergrundsicherung und auch mit kita
öffnungszeiten sei eine szene muss
allein erziehende mutter also man muss
das jetzt noch gar nicht buchen das kann
man auch nicht beurteilen wie sie ihren
job machen wird aber die sozusagen
absolute also unmöglichkeit dass zb
jetzt anton hofreiter der ja nach einem
ministeramt durchaus strebte und strebt
das der den familien minister macht das
finde ich also von vornherein ganz
schlecht für die politik und ich finde
es auch faszinierend dass
sozialdemokraten und grüne ist nun gar
nicht hinkriegen also die dass
ausgerechnet das familienministerium mal
anders zu besetzen also ist es ist immer
bei den linken ist es frauen sache und
es gab zwei historische familienminister
in denen den franz josef wermeling und
natürlich heiner geißler beides cdu
männer und bei noch nicht ohne erfolg im
amt war war großartig gemacht ja geben
völlig recht man kann übrigens auch
ämter qualifikation sehr viel besser
besetzen ohne dass man die geschlechter
austauscht also frau strack-zimmermann
wäre sicherlich nehme ich an eine sehr
viel bessere verteidigungsministerin als
frau lambrecht aber sie kann nicht sie
darf nicht weil sie es aus der fdp aus
der falschen partei
dass man beim regierungsbildung mal
anfängt von den qualifikationen her zu
denken und dann hinterher sieht wie man
das mit den parteien hinkriegt aber in
diesem fall war die spd sozusagen
diejenige die die suppe versalzen hat
weil die spd hatte ein vom verkündet
halbe-halbe halt männer halb frauen und
nachdem lauterbach gesundheitsminister
geworden war musste ins
verteidigungsministerium eine frau an
lassen die ja einmal ganz groß sebastian
geisler politikredaktion erklären wer
ist denn jetzt eigentlich die neue
familienministerin
wie heißt sie was macht sie um hier auch
nochmal ein zuschauer abzuholen er ist
lang haben lisa paus
alleinerziehende mutter ein des sohnes
sie ist eigentlich eine fachpolitikerin
eigene finanzpolitikerin und tatsächlich
muss ich sagen sie hat so eine gewisse
nervosität ist schon eine gestandene
politikerin die hat auch bereiche mit
denen sie sich gut auskennen sie hat ein
paar tagen noch eine ganz gute rede
gehalten auch im deutschen bundestag zum
thema inflation also der die ist jetzt
nicht irgendwer auch wenn sie weitgehend
unbekannt war aber was mich bei der
besetzung auch dieses postens zu ärgert
ist es hieß ganz klar es muss eine frau
sein es muss aus dem linken
landesverband muss sie kommen und dann
dieses als drittes kriterium ein mensch
damit die uns keine probleme jetzt schon
wieder macht wer das gut wenn die auch
noch ein bisschen kompetent wir und das
natürlich völlig falsche reihenfolge
warum nimmt man sich jemanden erstmal
kompetent ist und hat dann nachrangig
irgendwelche anderen kriterien das kann
man ja machen aus irgendwelchen
parteitaktischen erwägungen oder so aber
irgendwie so ja gut wäre gut wenn die
auch ein bisschen was drauf hätte das
irgendwie so irgendwie so nebenbei noch
das dass das ist doch dem normalbürger
auch überhaupt nicht zu vermitteln eine
eine solche eine solche auswahl von sich
gibt eben einen weiteren schlimmen trend
da kann man bei ford jetzt auch noch
nicht wissen ob er sich in ihrem
manifestiert oder nicht aber in einem
punkt ist ihre biografie der von frau
spiegeln ganz ganz ähnlich nämlich dass
sie kaum je außerhalb der politik
gearbeitet hat sie hat also innerhalb
der politik fast alle ämter innegehabt
die in der landes und bundespolitik
denkbar sind in ihrer partei und es ist
ja auch ein stück qualifikation also ich
bin keine anhängerin davon zu sagen es
sollen experten ganz von außerhalb
kommen die dann von politik wieder
nichts verstehen das funktioniert in der
regel dann auch nicht das ist eigentlich
auch häufig gescheitert dieser versuch
aber die gefahr und das wird immer mehr
und gerade bei den jüngeren wird es noch
mehr dass leute ihr ganzes leben in der
politik verbringen im prinzip nichts
anderes können und auch auf dem
arbeitsmarkt nicht anders vermittelbar
sind das schafft ja auch diese
abhängigkeiten jemand das hat im grunde
bei frau spiegel zu dieser völligen
verzweiflung geführt mit der sie am ende
sich an das amt geklammert hat weil die
frau steht jetzt auch vom nichts also
die ist ja auch direkt aus dem kabinett
in rheinland pfalz hier ins
bundeskabinett gewechselt die hatten
nicht mal ein bundestagsmandat also das
ist ja das war eigentlich hoch leben ja
wir haben viel zu viele leute die zum
beispiel studiert haben oder abgebrochen
oder ich eine frau nahles zum beispiel
unsere frühere spd vorsitzende
arbeitsministerin ja die hat glaube ich
mich vielleicht 20 semester der
germanistik studiert hat dann irgendwie
eine magisterarbeit über liebesromane
geschrieben hat dann angefangen genießt
aber mit der promotion ja und hat hat
dann irgendwie das nicht zu ende
gebracht ja und jetzt hat sie keinen job
gefunden ja weil es so jemand eigentlich
irgendwo gebraucht wird und deswegen
wird es dann praktisch oberste chefin
von jobcentern ja klingt wie ein märchen
ja und ohne abschluss ja aber das ist ja
leid weil ganz viel grün die haben ja
gerade mal zwei vorsitzende gewählt die
auch in abgeschlossen kein
abgeschlossenes studium haben das muss
jetzt nicht unbedingt dem sailer sein
also es gibt tolle leute ohne
abgeschlossenes studium zum beispiel
bill gates microsoft gegründet hat oder
so aber das ist ja jetzt dass auch ein
anderes kaliber und das finde ich im
grunde das größte problem dass wir genau
was ich sagen viele leute haben die nie
etwas anderes als politik kennen gelernt
studium und dann politik das gab es
früher auch schon muss man zugeben bei
helmut kohl war das auch letztlich nicht
viel anders ja aber es wird immer mehr
und jetzt habe ich aber eine gegenthese
doch mal andererseits das jetzt
insbesondere die linken parteien er
hatte ich ja jetzt nicht so mag ja dass
dies mit den ganzen quotierungen und so
weiter die stellen sich dann auch selbst
ein bein mit und das natürlich gar nicht
ganz gut als beispiel bei den grünen ist
ja so das wäre ja normalerweise hätte
der hupac das werden sollen ja jetzt ist
die paradoxe geworden und zwar durch
haben
als kandidat fand ich schon mal gut ja
oder bei der spd ist für die meisten
geworden ja so
die ja auch eigentlich außerhalb der spd
glaube ich jeder ziemlich unsympathisch
findet kann ich auch gut ja oder bei
linken haben sie also die hemmschwelle
sollte ja auch müssen unbedingt die
sympathieträgerin ist gewählt auch aus
solchen kontos insofern sage ich mal
dass die sich selbst ein bein mit
stellen ja da kann ich das wieder was
abgewinnen frau gesteht dass sie das
thema vorgetragen haben muss meine frage
stellen ich habe ja von der deppen
europas geredet sind die anderen länder
was die regierungsbildung angeht auch so
selbst gefesselt so verrückt
quotiert und und was die qualifikation
angeht eher witzig verirrt also es ist
das ist haben jetzt letzten endes im
detail könnte ich ihnen das für
frankreich gar nicht gar nicht
beantworten ich glaube was bei uns immer
dazu kommt ist ein wirklich ein
performative problem und da haben die
franzosen und auch die die italiener in
zwar immer mehr bella figura und vom
auftreten her einfach besser wir haben
das mit der quote so auf den punkt
gebracht nach dem motto da also da hat
qualifikation im grunde nachrangig zu
sagen also es ist so eine das steht mir
zu halten entstanden auch sozusagen in
einem bestimmten teil der feministin
organisierten frauen das dass man es
einfach so sehr sind da also ich nehme
an also wenn sie sich jetzt britische
kabinette angucken da haben sie auch
sehr unterschiedliche qualität so sein
da sieht man es auf anhieb da sieht man
es durchaus aber es ist wir haben also
durch dieses durch dieses verfahren
durch dieses vorgehen bringen desto
wahnsinnig deutsch auf den punkt und das
hat ja eine irrsinnige wirkung wir haben
ja im verteidigungsministerium seit
jahren berichtet darüber was da für ein
geld raus gehauen wird für
beratungsfirmen weil die leute die ich
in der spitze des ministeriums sitzen
keine ahnung haben und sich von iks
beratungsfirmen gutachten als ich an
solitaire eben auch gar nicht das kostet
an wahren satz geld hunderte von
millionen pro jahr völlig richtig dass
exzessive in anspruch nehmen von
beratungsfirmen ist ein großes problem
denn eigentlich ist das ministerium mit
seinen fachleuten dafür da die gesetze
auszuarbeiten und zu schreiben und nicht
irgendwelche externe beratungsfirma
warum dann millionenbeträge gerade frau
von der leyen bademeisterin aus aber
dafür das ist eigentlich eine
verschwendung von steuergeld hatte aber
wir haben jetzt eben sozusagen die
dritte verteidigungsministerin
nacheinander die sich also nicht
wahnsinnig oder diese vielleicht am
wenigsten überhaupt für truppe und und
ausrüstung interessiert und darf
natürlich langsam wirklich auch eine
zumutung flora und fauna die da die
absolute dienst tun und macht ein
bisschen angst was die
verteidigungsfähigkeit angehen halte
mich dass man da noch nichts von plänen
gehört hat ausführung der bundeswehr
wirklich demokratischen das stimmt ja er
wurde auch in einer sendung hier am
dienstag frau lambrecht ein
sicherheitsrisiko für unser land schon
als these auch dargestellt er wissen
gespannt was die regierung noch so in
den nächsten monaten macht und jetzt
kommen wir aber zu ihm der doktor doktor
sind immer ich muss sagen warum sich
zwei doktortitel ich bin ja gerne weil
ich hatte noch niemand nehmen wir sind
zwar damit dass
sie müssen mich auch noch mit einem an
aber ich habe zwei doktortitel war nicht
zwei doktorarbeiten geschrieben habe das
ist der ganz einfach und in welchen kann
das müssen auch sagen ihre geschichte
und in soziologie der geschichte da war
ich noch ganz jung und in soziologie das
ist erst sechs sieben jahre her jetzt
ich muss eigentlich freue mich sehr auf
ihre these 2 dr da fühle ich mich jetzt
gut
also ich hab kein aktuelles thema
mitgebracht weil ich auch der meinung
bin dass die wirklich wichtigen
änderungen oft gar nicht diesen sie sich
von heute auf morgen ergeben oder
aktuell sondern sind ganz langfristige
entwicklungen über die wir aber im
prinzip viel zu wenig reden und ich
möchte darüber eine änderung reden und
zwar dass die armut auf der ganzen welt
in den letzten jahrzehnten so stark
zurückgegangen ist wie noch nie in der
menschheitsgeschichte also noch vor 40
jahren da haben 43 prozent der menschen
auf der welt in extremer armut gelebt
heute ist weniger als zehn prozent oder
ich gehe noch mal ein bisschen weiter
zurück bevor der kapitalismus entstand
also sagen also 1820 da haben noch 90
prozent der menschen in extremer armut
gelebt 90 prozent auf der welt heute
weniger als zehn prozent und das ist
finde ich eine ganz bemerkenswerte
entwicklung über wer mit zu wenig
spricht und ja ich bin ein großer
anhänger vom kapitalismus jemand neues
buch da hab ich auch hoch halten hier
der antikapitalisten ja die zellen
irrtümer der anti kapitalisten und ja
das ist ein großer irrtum großer
ethikrat dass man sagt also der
kapitalismus ist für hunger und armut
auf der welt verantwortlich nein ich
sage genau das gegenteil der
kapitalismus ist dafür verantwortlich
dass die armut so stark zurückgegangen
ist wie noch nie in der geschichte und
das wissen die meisten menschen nicht
und darüber wird nicht geredet und
deswegen sage ich es heute mal er
erstens stimme ich ihnen zu also das
stimmt ganz sicher ich glaube ihnen auch
alle zahlen los muss ich einschränkend
sagen die menschen leben in den
statistiken und den zahlen sondern die
empfinden armut also wenn und das gibt
es heute zweifellos selbst in
deutschland dass menschen mit jedem euro
rechnen müssen merkt man ja gerade jetzt
wo die energiepreise steigen und die
preise generell steigen da kriegt man
mal gelegentlich sieht man mal oder
liest man mal was leute kein geld zur
verfügung haben ein verfügbares
einkommen für lebensmittel und andere
dinge und das ist schon ziemlich
schockierend ehrlich gesagt da gibt es
sehr viele denen es schlecht geht im
prinzip haben sie aber recht ich möchte
kein anderes wirtschaftssystem haben ich
fühle mich in der sozialen
marktwirtschaft wohl
und da muss man an einigen dingen noch
arbeiten aber
wir sollten ein bisschen nicht nicht so
sehr auf die zahlen schauen sondern auf
die menschen die in ihnen leben nicht
mal fragen welchen parametern machen sie
es fest also es ist ja immer dieses
ringen darum was ist eigentlich
fortschritt nicht möglich
wird bei uns die diskussion so an als
hätten wir gar keinen fortschritt und
dann kann man natürlich von
lebenserwartung oder zahngesundheit bis
bis zu was heisst was auch immer die
veränderung der lebensweise
verbesserung der öffentlichen räume also
sehr viel aufzählen was
selbstverständlich unendlich viel besser
geworden ist aber was sind für diesen
armut begriff die die parameter also
also sozusagen zum wasser zugang zu
bildung hunger so gut dass und
definition von der von der weltbank nach
kriterien messen aber ich will es mal
dass ich so abstrakt das soll diesmal am
konkreten beispiel erklären also china
ich war oft in china und was viele
menschen nicht wissen noch ende der 50er
jahre sind 540 millionen menschen 45
millionen hungern und am größten
sozialistische experiment der
menschheitsgeschichte umgekommen warm
aus sogenannter großer sprung nach vorne
also ich halte vorträge überall auf der
welt über diese themen und fragt ob du
die leute wer hat das wert in der schule
was gehört von maus großen sprung nach
vorne wo 45 millionen menschen
umgekommen sie haben sie was gehört in
der schule ich versage in der synthese
weil leider dann wärst du dich genau ja
ist ja wunderbar finde ich habe ihn aber
es ist halt ganz oft nicht der fall
jetzt nur noch mal eine zahl noch
1981 haben 88 prozent der chinesen
extreme armut gelebt heute weniger als 1
warum war deng xiaoping dann irgendwann
nach maos tod privateigentum geführt hat
eingeführt hat marktwirtschaft
eingeführt hat ja und er will ja niemand
mehr zurück zur zeit nur weil die
menschen nach gleicher waren und aber
ich habe nur ein bisschen demokratie
genauso kann man das totalitäre system
china überhaupt zum beispiel mit
deutschland vergleichen und die zweite
frage die hat aber jetzt schon vollgas
ja auch gesagt gehabt wissen demokratie
wäre wahrscheinlich schon auch ganz
natürlich bin jetzt keinen fürsprecher
von china das ist ein totalitäres system
ich rede jetzt nur ein von der
wirtschafts form als wir müssen ein
bisschen zwischen der politik und
wirtschaft und erscheinen und bei der
wirtschaft muss man sagen da ist einfach
die einführung von marktwirtschaft im
privaten eigentum hat den chinesen sehr
gut getarnt übrigens deutschen auf bald
wenn china nicht also als
handelspartner hätten ja dann weiß ich
wie es in deutschland heute auch ja ist
vermutlich das land in dem der
kapitalismus am ungebremsten wirkt also
also ich war ja da und hat mit den
vertretern aber wir brauchen ja in china
und der hat mir gesagt also wir sind
hier die letzten verteidiger des
kapitalismus bei uns glaubt kein mensch
mehr an karl marx alle das muss man
sagen leider ändert sich das im moment
ein bisschen wieder also es gibt zwar
ein index der ökonomischen freiheit und
da hat china im letzten jahr ganz stark
abgenommen und ich bin auch befreundet
mit einem ökonomen also von der peking
universität und der sagt mir leider geht
es im moment wieder ein bisschen in die
entgegengesetzte richtung das wäre ganz
schlimm weil der ganze fortschritte in
china gemacht hat der sagt wir immer das
war nicht wegen dem staat sondern
trotzdem statt und das verstehen aber
hier viele nicht ja denn wenn sie das
ist ja das eigentlich dass der kern
ihrer botschaft ja wenn man das an home
ist und am extremen elend menschen
umkommen durch krankheiten und hunger
dann das ist ganz sicher besser geworden
und das mache ich jetzt immer nur als
neben bemerkungen wir nehmen ja jetzt
auch zur kenntnis dass ich wusste das
schon lange aber die ist das große
problem nimmt zur kenntnis dass auch in
der ukraine durch stalin millionen von
menschen verhungert
worden lassen sind das habe ich ein
bisschen schräg ausgedrückt star lena
darunter millionen von menschen
umgebracht durch hunger und das war
gezielte politik um die ukraine die für
bürgerlich gehalten würden bauern
kulaken die land besaßen die mussten
umgebracht werden also als 80 wir denken
bei hunger heute an afrika
logischerweise immer aber der hunger
auch groß ist aber toll oder
80 prozent der menschen die bei
hungersnöten umgekommen sind waren in
china und in russland gewesen da war es
auch was viele menschen nicht wissen
aber herr doktor doktor titel mannes
ebenfalls nicht selbst angesprochen das
ist ein großes problem dass in unseren
schulen haben ja viele so auch so sehr
relativ linke lehrer dann gerne mal
sozialkunde unterrichten dass dort den
schülern den jungen menschen eigentlich
überhaupt nicht mehr vermittelt wird
teilweise ganz im gegenteil was die
grundlagen unseres wohlstands hier sind
und wie wertschöpfung stattfindet und so
etwas dann kommen dann irgendwie so
kleine linke dann irgendwie bei raus und
gut und manche schüler haben auch ein
gemüse irgendwie widerspruchsgeist
vielleicht aber das halte ich für ein
großes problem es bräuchte eigentlich
wie so was wie im fach wirtschaft in der
schule oder so es muss den leuten
vermietet werden worauf eigentlich wie
wo das alles herkommt was uns
ausmacht oder freiheit und demokratie
funktioniert es ja nach unserem
verständnis nicht wirklich deswegen ist
china immer ein problematisches beispiel
und realisieren was die
wirtschaftskenntnisse angeht total recht
geben aber auf der anderen seite ist
weiß auch kein mensch für unser
politisches system funktioniert die
allermeisten leute wissen nicht den
unterschied zwischen erst und
zweitstimme und ehrlich gesagt seitdem
deutschen verfassungsgerichts urteil
verstehe ich also auch nicht mehr ganz
wie die mandate für bundestag noch
ausgeglichen werde nur dass der immer
grösser wird dadurch aber insofern also
auch die kenntnisse der neueren
deutschen geschichte ich meine also sein
wir sind noch so bis zum dritten reich
gekommen und dann vielleicht noch also
sowieso gründung der bundesrepublik so
eben gerade noch und dann war's das und
die darbietung sagt dieses jahr
vielleicht genau ddr kommt gar nicht
habe ich es vielleicht auch lehrer
abhängig zum beispiel wenn ich das jetzt
höre muss ich gleich glaube ich danach
als meine karte meiner ehemaligen
geschichtslehrer schreiben ich hatte das
alles im geschichtsunterricht wo war das
dorf in der nähe aber er sagen will ist
also mich ich glaube dass es auch einen
engagierten lehrern gibt zum beispiel
ich ja überhaupt keine ahnung von chemie
und physik und denken immer hätte ich
mal spannendere lehrer gehabt wird sich
vielleicht wegen die grundkenntnisse was
immer das so wenn ich glaube muss man
dann nicht eher sagen vielleicht müssen
lehrer besser ausgebildet werden auch
vielleicht mehr geld verdienen weil ich
glaube es hängt doch immer mit aber erst
vier stunden also uns gibt es ja keine
wirtschaft es gibt manchmal nur noch
eine stunde geschichte pinkeln also ich
habe da eine ganz andere also wirtschaft
in der schule finde ich klasse aber wenn
der lehrer das ist der höchste gehalt
ist nicht so viel davon weil der lehrer
der hat doch nie angerührt eigentlich
mit der wirtschaftlich schule gegangen
dann ist die uni gegangen dann ist er
wieder zurück in die schule getragen für
eine wirtschaft hatte nie was
mitgekriegt also ich wäre für was
anderes dass man sagt wir laden jede
woche einmal ein unternehmer ein in die
schule der erzählt wie er die firma
gegründet hat die firma aufgebaut hat ja
etwas über unternehmertum begeistert
dann vielleicht junge menschen für
unternehmertum das kann ich den ball
immer besser als lehrer einmal zurück zu
ihrer anfangs these die sender in der
tat schon spannend ja auch wenn man dann
natürlich drüber lange diskutieren kann
sie sagen ja die armut zurückgedrängt
worden und zwar auf dem globus generell
ja auch in der dritten welt das so
genannte in afrika überall
wir haben aber trotzdem
ich will ich aber nicht relativieren wir
haben große flucht bewegungen und so
weiter aber ich will sich anders sagen
wir lernen doch wir lesen über all die
armen werden immer ärmer und die reichen
werden immer reicher das ist doch eine
zu einer gebetsmühlenhaft formulierung
geworden in deutschland
wobei man dann schon mal untersuchen
muss wie wird denn armut überhaupt die
von der definiert was ist die die
grundlage einer solchen statistik aber
sie aber sie tun es ja in ihrem buch die
leute müssen um sich mit dem thema zu
beschäftigen mit dieser general formel
die reichen immer reicher die armen
immer ärmer müssen die andere daten
haben die dem widersprechen damit man
überhaupt diskussionsfähig wird deshalb
ist ihre these wichtig das finde ich
toll oder nena
der eine zeit vom satz das stück auch
irgendwo klar die reichen werden immer
reicher gerade auch in letzter zeit aber
das ist ja nicht verkehrt dass das ist
ja nichts schlechtes das sind für mich
zwei seiten einer medaille
also weil ich von über china geredet
habe ich habe gesagt wie ist die zahl
der armen zurückgegangen aber
gleichzeitig ist die zahl der
milliardäre so stark gestiegen wie in
keinem andern land also heute gibt es so
viele milliardäre in china wie den usa
und übrigens in peking als new york was
viele leute gar nicht wissen ja das
heißt also das sind zwei seiten einer
medaille
und das ist ja dieser nullsummen glauben
immer die leute an die denken ja der
arme ist nur an weil der reiche ihm was
weggenommen hat dann wären ja diese
ganze entwicklung gar nicht verständlich
also heute gibt es fünf mal mehr
milliardäre auf der welt als noch vor 20
jahren aber die armut ist gleichzeitig
gesunken das war der letzte gedanke für
heute vielen herzlichen dank an meine
gäste hans ulrich jörges susanne gaschke
doktor doktor rein das ist auch an
hilfen zeit muss sein und sebastian
geisler wenn sie mögen scheißen sie
dienstag wieder ein bisschen abend noch
machen sie es gut
[Musik]